okay we are
live uh why am I streaming on a Sunday I
have no idea
but I felt like doing a bit of
work and I figured I may as well stream
it not going to be doing stuff all day
today um just like want to start on a
few
things yeah
so there's still some unsolved problems
here but I at the same time I want to
start thinking
about a minimal implementation of
carbs so I'm just going to start
scrolling through here and seeing what
stuff I think we w't
need okay a million dumb Imports
that's dozen lines of imports at least
it'll be gone
go okay this is just super convoluted
logic
bizarre okay s yeah
fine
what single sample can only be better if
it is is better than the max the
previous
group multi- sample group can be higher
can be better if the mean is higher
transform herf
plot duplicated all this code
that's all that's in
here these other ones we will
um oh actually there's yeah there's just
expect
Improvement but this for instance
okay let's see what else I'm haven't
seen get
resample non-conservative version so we
can
and then let's see what they did here
they
[Music]
did failed to count so they did do some
good
logging for
so you know they
actually I got to give them some credit
here because when I'm looking at what a
lot of the code is for uh it's not as
bad as I originally thought they still
have way more code than they need and I
think that that's probably why they're
so confused here and why there are so
many things that are just like I don't
know
hazy
like things here don't make sense some
decisions seem poorly motivated and I
think it's just if you had half this
amount of code um you know things would
be clearer so I think that's what I'm
going to just start on doing
I think we'll just do this directly in
puffer live as well so so what I'll do
then
actually one thing I want to do first
here before we start
this I want to see if we can
um just real quick
grab some hypers from the latest sweep
so we run an experiment
while this is
what the
hell
hello
environment oh
still no all right I don't know what you
doing Neptune I'll just click it like
this and hope it doesn't lag too bad
best I really need to be able to filter
this
896 there we
are here's the chart for this
one this is very
good we'll just go grab the
let's see how different the progams are
for
this okay substantially lower learning
rate
interesting the
score uh let's not forget the N Pam
here even lower at 512 is
interesting so that's a very slow uh
very slow run it's still
300K entropy coefficient has been taken
all the way down to the minimum
value
Lambda is a little higher which is odd a
gamma being higher oh no it's not odd
yeah these are longer Maps this makes
perfect sense this is like a text
book exactly what you would
expect mini batch
size 16k but it says four mini batches I
believe what do you pass in here you do
pass in mini batch size
right yeah you pass in mini bat
that mini batch size gets passed in is
this it's actually probably one of the
things that made it difficult but we can
get rid of
that total time step this
is 180
mil upd dep box of
size I did it for the ones with
extremely low mini batches it looks
like that's fine we'll leave it alone
for now we'll just not sweep this
one okay
okay well hey
things so now we have this Baseline up
and running we can go work on our hyper
pram sweep
stuff I think I'm going to make
this yeah of
course
IG well what's
imported puffer
lib so let's see the main uh the main
stuff we're going to want
top carbs
prms basically done hugging face some of
the lectures of David
Silvers let me see is the hugg and face
course
good I think Costa was involved which
means it should
be good cost is like the best he's
awesome I've worked with him quite a bit
in the
past oh yeah this is
good yeah this is very
nice okay so the only thing really
missing from here
is some
formalism uh let me just ask you are you
for what purpose are you looking to get
into reinforcement learning are you
interested in getting into the science
side of RL are you trying to build stuff
are you trying to use this at work like
what purpose and then I can tell you I
can direct you from
there cuz the answer is going to vary
quite a bit depending on what you're
trying to do
also your background is your background
are you more mathematically inclined
more engineering inclined you like both
you like
flattening F TL after
working quite some time in LM
research fair enough I technically
started in uh natural language
processing as well though that was
before Transformers EX justed
here it's just going to be that um this
is
not hey what's going on just doing a
little bit of morning work on a Sunday I
don't know probably going to do this for
a bit then uh get breakfast go for a run
do a couple non RL things for a bit
catch up on some other random admin and
other work and then chill for a
bit normally I do uh I'd be going for
long runs on Sundays but
um it's going to take a little bit to
get back into that into the shape to be
able to be running for like 3
hours pneumonia is no joke
so I don't know probably just do like
five six miles
today but currently I'm uh I'm just like
it's this why it's going to be slow here
I have an existing stack of crazy
abstractions and I'm trying to figure
out how to piece them apart and like
simplify
everything want to get good at RLS a top
up and also try to do something in
agentic Ai and post training okay so
that's going to be a
very very different set of things from
what I'm usually doing because to give
you an idea right what I do in
RL uh we do like ultra high
performance training of small models for
the most part so like we have things
like this we have things
like uh things like
this we've got you know things like this
and these all train hundreds of
thousands to a million steps per second
on a single GPU so we're looking at perf
optimizations of like way more than a
th000 x maybe 10,000 or
100,000x um what you're looking at with
language models because it actually
matters
um you're
probably I mean there are definitely
some things in RL that will help you
though if you are trying to work in that
space like getting good at General RL uh
will be useful the thing that's tricky
at the moment is RL as a field has not
received the level of
investment um that the rest of AI has
received so a lot of stuff it's kind of
just feels janky and like the thing
that's tricky is I could tell you to see
uh I could tell you to just go through
my quick start guide and there are a
bunch of papers here right there papers
here this is probably good perspective
at the very least and in fact this video
is also good perspective not this one I
have a video on it's I think it's pinned
on my homepage on x
it kind of lays out how I'm looking at
RL right now and it's still pretty well
current I know I pinned the
trailer did I highlight it at least yeah
here it is it's on highlight it's full
RL Iceberg um that'll kind of give you
some insight because the thing is the
papers paint a very different picture
from reality uh the vast majority of
papers in RL are just wrong or they
present at least a misleading view
because uh the results tend really not
to generalize very well from one
environment to the next because RL
researchers don't run enough experiments
because they don't have compute to run
enough experiments because their
environments are too slow so I'm working
on that tail under the loop we make
things slow we run more experiments we
do research correctly the science gets
corrected and RL actually makes sense
again but if you're not going all the
way down to that end of the stack at
least I think it'll be useful to have
some perspective while reading through
and getting like a literature background
in RL that a lot of these things are not
as clear-cut as they are
presented get well soon oh no I'm better
I was I was in the hospital though for
you know several days it was a close
call frankly um but the main thing is
it's just like yeah I lost close to 20
lbs and a good chunk of my lung capacity
so I was in fantastic shape beforehand
luckily which is what saved me but um
it's going to be probably a good six
months of training to get my weight back
to get my fitness back to be you know
marathoning and powerlifting properly
again what's puffer lib doing I just
scroll through channels and see a lot of
streams on it so this is uh I mean I'm
an MIT PhD puffer AI is a startup it's
all open source and free this is my
effort to fix reinforcement learning
this is me trying to make all of
reinforcement learning simple consistent
and ridiculously high performance and
it's all done as an open- source project
with contributors developing new
environments people coming in and
picking up RL and helping out using
their you know their engineering skills
so to give you an idea here all of these
are environments they're all playable
online they're all written in C they're
all about a thousand times faster than
what you'll find in most of the rest of
reinforcement learning and we're
developing more of these we're using
these to do science very very
efficiently uh to make reinforcement
learning sane and consistent this is my
attempt at revolutionizing an important
subfield what I see is a probably one of
the most underappreciated areas of AI
and Tech that is what puffer is and
there's lots of content around it
there's this blog post I have lots of
stuff on X there's this whole community
on Discord and of course all the codes
open source
so that is what this is
and you know I stream all the work for
various reasons but uh it's been uh it's
been a good time for the most part
um yeah this interface sucks
so this we're going to keep puffer carbs
pin yeah this is kind of nuts if you're
looking at
this making a certain part of puffer lib
puffer lib is my project so I mean this
is I just stream my development on it at
the moment I'm working on uh improving
hyperparameter sweeps so it's a
combination of you know engineering new
environments uh I look at existing
research papers and I try to improve
things there we run way more rigorous
tests than are done in the vast majority
of science right we're able to do that
because of the performance of puffer lib
it's just all around we try to fix
various areas of uh of
RL all the previous
ones certain part all the previous ones
ones yeah I mean all the dev streams are
just me working on various things in
puffer lib um most of it is it's
actually kind of split now most of it is
just me advancing the areas of core
puffer development that I think are
going to be important we have a couple
contracts with companies um so sometimes
I do client stuff but the way it's set
up is like the only thing that puffer
sells to companies is uh essentially a
service package so it's like hey we want
this thing to work better with puffer
lib and then I'll go make it actually
work with puffer lib and because
everything's open source it's still I'd
still do it on
stream it's generally good time this is
a relatively new company I just
graduated this past
spring and already the progress has been
absolutely nuts um you know we've made
our like a thousand times faster in 8
months or
whatever so it's definitely going well
there are few areas that I think need to
be improved and this is one of the major
ones at the moment this is a difficult
area to improve but uh I'm working on it
it's hyper parameter sweeps
LMS basically all the knowledge is in
the pre-train
model sftl does reformulates
probability well because the pre-train
model is just it's a completion model
model right uh like Max probability of
next token which is very far from from a
usability perspective that's very far
from how you would want to interact with
a model uh and how you would like it to
apply all that so basically you have a
generic compression algorithm and you
need to know how to steer it the
hypothesis right is that compression is
intelligence um and then the RL is how
do you steer that because you know it
having the world's best zip program
right is not on its own that doesn't
solve stuff on its own you have to steer
it do you think this kind of thank you
yeah uh do you think this kind of RL
being done which is bringing up good
samples in topk will hit a limit yeah I
look that's like grpo I just saw um it's
frankly really if I understand that
algorithm correctly and I only took a
quick look at it um it's really
embarrassing say I think that the rest
of the field didn't figure that out
earlier because it's a very basic
modification of PPO uh to add top K
which is like something that they've
know everyone has known for years works
really well with language models it's
also something that I would have never
tried in what I do because like it just
makes the algorithm way more
expensive um so yeah I don't
that's kind of weird I don't know if
that hits limits or not uh do I think
that RL I do I think that the current
language models as they are right now
with grpo and R1 and everything do I
think that that's going to solve the set
of all problems we ever care about no
that's why I'm working on this
right I think RL is they're missing a
lot of pieces in RL because frankly
what's being done on language models in
RL right now is very
basic it has to be very basic they can't
run any experiments their experiments
are too
expensive you never try anything
remotely crazy when your experiments
cost millions of dollars to
run I guess a couple hundred thousand in
the case of their um fine-tuning but
still generating a lot of
samples yep well the funny thing is
you're not even generating that many
samples you're doing RL with like no
data you know that uh in puffer we
actually can train on more data than all
of say gp4 on one GPU in a few
days that's the difference in scale that
we're looking at
here llms have crazy compute scale crazy
numbers of parameters but actually very
little
data very very little data and we also
have uh we also have some pretty good
empirical and theoretic medical evidence
that um reinforcement learning generally
requires more samples uh per model size
like 10x more samples at least compared
to language
models in generative learning which
makes sense because reinforcement
learning uh the way that the loss is
constructed you get less
information uh out of each sample so you
need more
wer lip seems cool thank
you it's really nice to be able to just
see all the environments on here like
the thing that tells me that I think
that we're on the right
track I think this is just a render
bug b
ago that was weird
um the thing that tells me that I think
that we're on the right track so this is
basically I worked on neural MMO for my
whole PhD and then in like 3 months I
built a version of it around you know
using the ideas and the approaches of
puffer uh this
version is way larger more complex more
visually impressive runs on web and is a
thousand times faster than anything I
built during my PhD with like less than
a third of the
code
so yeah it's an exciting time it's a lot
of work mind you we've already shipped I
think like puffer is about 30,000 lines
of code right now and it's not 30,000
lines of garbage either like it's 30,000
lines pretty darn dense of of good stuff
the core is only a few thousand lines
but then it's 20,000 lines of
environments and that's growing
rapidly we have all sorts of
contributors over 10,000 of that is from
contributors yeah so it's actually like
a decent chunk of puffer Li is made by
contributors many of whom came in with
zero prior RL experience basically
anybody who's like can write decent code
and is willing to learn learn stuff um
and will like PR cool new environments I
just you know I train on the RL side um
as they go so now we have like you know
multiple new people who are submitting
awesome new environments and who are
getting pretty good at the RL side as
we're going to take all this for now
we're not going to take all of it thanks
look forward to maybe learn contribute
yeah thank you stop by streams you know
join the Discord if you like we organize
all the stuff on
there not for LM specifically but for uh
for General RL this is the place to be
at the moment I would not be doing this
full time unless I really thought that
there was uh was something there you
know fortunately my job ends up
including cleaning up thousands and
thousands of lines of code from
Academia but uh you know we do a little
this oh you can seed it I doubt that's
reproducible
but also we're getting rid of these
freaking annotations I hate type
annotations in Python so
much they don't do
anything the only reason you need them
is because you're overbuilding
everything
radius look at all this like adder
validator
perm actually this is very easy to
paraliz as well the way I'm looking at
it
we're actually going to keep this
structured
here uh this is going to be something
like samples for
cost minimum cost for prito
set to be this percentile of cost data
one we're not doing this
okay so this entire now this whole carbs
pram thing is just gone replaced with
only a few lines
here and actually I think that that uh
this comment will go where we actually
use
it now we got to go look at what
actually is in carbs and their in nit
function
it's actually funny because I in my head
I have no idea how I'm planning on like
restructuring their code I just kind of
go through it and fix small things one
at a time but uh I've done this exact
thing like four or five times this past
couple weeks with what I do here oh
nothing um
uh I did this like four or five times
with different academic repos and
it's always produced like ridiculously
simplified code there's just so much to
cut like what I'm doing now wouldn't do
anything if the code were like within
mostly reasonable bounds of complexity
it's just so over complicated that
there's just so much to
cut it's pretty basic as well
a lot of
this I mean I say that but I
definitely there's definitely like I'm
way better at this now than I would have
been
before decisions would have been made
this don't need
this real number bace by name
this actually because these are objects
I can get a flat
need I'd rather keep most of this in
numpy you
know it's not faster the way they're
doing
it in fact their code was horribly
join the community looking forward to it
great thanks for dropping
by oops I don't like when it tries to
have complete too much for
me this is fine except I don't like the
type annotation
I don't need to annotate this as a list
because it's obviously a list and you
don't need to know what type of object
it is if I don't make some big fancy
object it's probably just going to be a
dictionary
yes I think in a second yeah I'm going
to
go do a couple quick things I'll be back
in uh I don't know 5 10 minutes
is then we'll do a little bit more on
this another hour or so be right
I'm
back very eloquent Mr pepper
that about matches what we wanted as
well
oh it's actually not terrible at
exploring
now got stuck all the way down that end
of the maze Holy look at
that ah they got stuck
there it's weird they get stuck there I
wonder if there's no there's not a bug
it took me quite some time to realize
neural MMO with
you
yeah well I mean I don't know I might
change it now the thing is that for a
while right uh people knew me from
neural MMO more but now puffer lips
cotton I think bigger than neural MMO
ever was at least if you look at like
GitHub Stars contributors discords about
the same size or getting to be and uh
the neural Discord had like three
competitions worth of participants in
it concerns me when the puffer just gets
fully stuck like that that's kind of
weird so you can see here like this
thing is it's running around quite a bit
um but it's still
not it's not exploring the way that you
would want like a maze solver to explore
it's pretty decent
that one actually took me a second to
see the path
on that's a hard maze for it it's got to
go all the way
some of the mazes are pretty hard for
it this one has like a very
clear backtrack all the
oh yeah look at that it even figured out
that one that's good
whoa okay this is a pretty decent little
model this model's like 170k parameters
by the way it's
tiny this is the first sweep I ever ran
on uh on these uh bigger
Maps okay we'll do some cars stuff now
but there you
go Ram from
basic
that let try
this search distribution
no we're not doing a distribution we're
not going to have that thingy
around subjects or observe lock I hate
this we're getting rid of this I don't
think we need this either
numb dims with
bounds we don't
e I wonder if there's some way to do
this whole thing as one
run I don't know if there's a way to do
your whole hyperr sweep is like one
contiguous run
function
oops wrong
button I mean these are both of the
functions that we
need let's see how much
uh how much smaller these can be
resample was this config resample
frequency for
so this is their
basic sample logic right
here let me just finish the uh the full
chain
yeah so this
is this is fine this is like roughly
what it'll look like
um well I have an idea for how to return
it as a structured
value we'll get to
that so it's really just implementing
this this logic
here generate
okay so we can get rid of this function
cuz we no longer need this as a
template and we may as well just put the
observe stuff in
here uh there's literally nothing
here and observation yeah there's
nothing in here that's
okay what I'm going to do real
quick I don't I can actually navigate
space holy hell look at like the how
nested this is you see this
right I don't see how anybody codes like
this like just how do you how do you
keep track of what you're doing when you
Nest everything this
deep see this is the actual piece of
code that we want but it was five levels
deep AI IDE
it's very difficult for me to see a
point in which you are you as a
programmer are using your skill
productively somehow right you're
actually adding something but you're
letting an AI write like entire blocks
of code for you
I much prefer um single line complete
which is basically just a better LSP
it's just like a typing
buff like you can see while I'm typing
right I do have ai auto complete on but
you see I use it for like on line
completes right like if I just do like
def you see right
here it just it makes me type A about
twice as fast that's all it
does and prevents me from having to like
allocate brain space to remembering uh
to remembering my variable names and
such but I still do pay attention to my
variable
names yeah but stuff like cursor and all
these like people are not just tabing
like if you're just tabing you don't
need an IDE right you need a plugin for
whatever you're currently
using people who are using whole IDE
built around this are like filling in
giant blocks and
such it would be nice for this to have a
little bit more context you know it
would be nice to be able to initialize
this with context of my code base so it
picks up more variable names and such um
but that's like again that's still a
plugin I see so they're using torch here
for the sampling
sample
huh
origin
samples origins in
oh I guess it's because they use this
for
um I see
so the reason it's like this is because
they also use this function
for uh for their Paro
I think that this is for this one is
just a
and then what is
this search
center plus search scale
I could see why having this be separate
would be
what the hell is this thing why did they
make
this oh they want you to control your
RNG but that's kind of silly by default
sense actually maybe this would
be maybe this would be
useful right because probably your
seating
issues your probably your seating issues
do come from this
but we're not going to worry about that
for
now so this is Randon um
I think this is the whole
thing I could be wrong but this is this
should be your fantasy sampler
all you need to do is pass the
um your parito points
it should be something
like something like this
oh actually you literally don't need to
do this I'm dumb this goes
here this is your uh
the resample you can't do this for
actually so we'll leave it yeah it's
only two of three that you can uh copy
the code for
it now there's going to have to be some
sort of
amusingly enough this is uh not that far
off of already being a
complete uh implementation of I mean a
substantially simplified one without any
of the
models but this is like a Pito
optimal Pito optimal genetic search
essentially
be funny if that actually worked very
well wouldn't be surprised
unnormalized happens at the very
end which I guess her Baseline is right
here
just need a way to rebuild the
dictionary as
all I mean here's a really stupid
way
okay we'll write something uh we'll
write something quick for
and then this just needs to get the
parito points from
observations let's figure out how to do
that
do for
now just pick one of
computation and this is
a
relatively uh well I got to go grab the
spaces and clean those
Adder dos where did they get this Adder
thing
class oh this
is this is uh that's funny yeah we're
not using that
howy okay we'll keep this pretty similar
to their thing for now though I I don't
like it so we're going to
probably uh we're probably going to
change some
stuff for
normal thing is so bad
CL unnormalized
we're cutting some fat off of
carbs and by some I
mean what's that famous uh
quote cutting off F if you uh if you
rendered it you could make soap to wash
the world or
something it's one of
those can't you just do this now wait on
class classes without having
to do anything
it's like look at how much extra clutter
they add and they don't give you
anything they're not even
enforced all right and we'll clean up
this math I'm sure as
well I think I think that's about all
you need
is I think you just you add is integer
at the top as
go so that is a
basic I'm sure not working but that is a
basic implement M
ation I should
go do what I need to do go for my run
and stuff before it gets too hot outside
today um we're going to see how I'm
feeling I might come back and do some of
this in the afternoon I'm enjoying this
uh I should also rest a little and do
catch up on a couple other little other
work things but uh we'll see I think is
is important so I might come back to
this in the
afternoon um for folks
watching all this stuff is free and open
source you can check out puff. for all
of our demos here these all run on the
web if you want to help us out for free
just start the repository really really
helps really does and if you want to get
involved with development or just
following the
project join the disc
support got a whole bunch of orl
Articles and stuff on the blog here and
if you want even more you can follow my
X where there are some additional things
you can't find anywhere else in the
Articles and I post a bunch about
RL the uh the quotes from a US president
I forget which one was talking about the
government but uh it's a funny quote
anyways thank you uh thanks folks and uh
I I will